merci vos rapporteurs en tout cas n'ont
pas eu besoin de chat piti pour répondre
à ses amendements répétitifs qui tirent
vers l'obstruction d'ailleurs poser la
question à chaque gipiti s'il a
répétition permet de faire avancer le
débat et nous donnons effectivement un
avis un avis et nous donnant un avis
défavorable au rapport c'est parce que
nous avons vu faire comme Madame
Rossignol était ministre elle donnait un
avis négatif à l'ensemble des rapports
parce qu'il n'était pas suffisamment
déposé rat plus rappelez-vous madame
Rossignol rappelez-vous c'est la raison
pour laquelle effectivement nous donnera
un avis de négatif
[Musique]